[Musique]
se faire vacciner en musique ce vendredi
le pianiste iulian hockey ce coup offert
quelques distractions musical aux
romains venus se faire injecter une dose
de sérum jusqu'à lundi du cac reste
organise son marathon de la vaccination
dix stands ont été installés ici à la
bibliothèque nationale de roumanie et 40
autres os à la pala tout louis une salle
de concert située également dans le
centre de la capitale roumaine 1200
bénévoles participent à ce marathon
médecins infirmières étudiants ou
simples résidents qui se relaient pour
vacciner 24 heures sur 24 tous ceux qui
se présentent même sans rendez vous de
quoi permettre l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination voulue par
l'exécutif roumains ce qui est le plus
important c'est qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui en roumanie et je ne pense
pas que nous ayons un autre exemple
comme celui ci en europe
vous pouvez aller vous faire vacciner
sans prendre de rendez-vous vous
choisissez un centre de vaccination et
vous allez simplement vous faire
vacciner
c'est un effort que nous avons fait en
nous assurant d'avoir suffisamment de
doses pour que tous les roumains qui
veulent se faire vacciner puissent le
faire sans devoir faire la queue
j'espère que cet effort sera apprécié
que nous désirons tous retrouver une vie
normale le plus rapidement possible sans
faire la queue pas vraiment mais
l'opération semble avoir rencontré son
public
d'autres marathons ont déjà été
organisées ailleurs dans le pays et
bucarest a ouvert il ya une dizaine de
jours son premier centre de vaccination
au volant il faut dire que la roumanie
accuse du retard face à bon nombre de
membres de lieux
à ce jour environ 5,6 millions de
personnes ont reçu une première dose
soit moins d'un roumain sur cinq bien en
dessous de la moyenne de l'union
européenne